SYSTEM.
WE HAVE MORE ON THAT LATER
IN THE PROGRAM.
JOINING US NOW FIRST, MORE
ON OUR TOP STORY, WE START
TONIGHT WITH OUR RADIO TALK
SHOW HOST, SYNDICATED HOST
LARRY ELDER.
FRIEND, LET ME START WITH
THE SHUTDOWN AND THE
PRESIDENT.
THE 'THE HAS INVITED THE
DEMOCRAT DAY AFTER DAY TO
COME AND NEGOTIATE TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT IS LIFE AND DEATH
AT THE BORDER AND TALK ABOUT
THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
THEY NEVER GO THEY DON'T
WANT TO NEGOTIATE.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT ACTED
IN THE RIGHT WAY TODAY.
>> I AGREE.
SEAN, THIS IS WHAT GETS ME
OF ALL THINGS NANCY PELOSI
OF ALL PEOPLE OUGHT TO
UNDERSTAND THE POSITION
DONALD TRUMP IS IN.
HE MADE A CAMPAIGN PROMISE,
NOT JUST A CAMPAIGN PROMISE
BUT A PROMISE HE BELIEVES
MAKES THE COUNTRY BETTER.
SIMILARLY 2008 BARACK OBAMA
RUN, ONE OF THE SIGNATURE
POLICIES WHAT WAS HEALTHCARE
REFORM WHICH HE CALLED
OBAMACARE.
IT WAS UNPOPULAR TO THE
POINT WHERE MASSACHUSETTS, A
DEMOCRATS LOST THE SO-CALLED
TED KENNEDY SEAT TO SCOTT
BROWN.
THEY WERE DEMORALIZED, SEAN,
THEY WERE CRUREND.
RAHM EMANUEL WANTED TO PULL
THE WHOLE THING.
THE PERSON THAT BUCKED OBAMA
UP THAT SAID GO BIG OR GO
HOME WAS NANCY PELOSI.
SHE SAID YOU MADE A
SIGNATURE PROMISE, YOU NEED
TO FULFILL IT.
AND DONALD TRUMP MADE A
PROMISE AND HE IS TRYING TO
DO THE SAME THING TO FULFILL
A CAMPAIGN PROMISE THAT HE
MADE THAT HE ALSO BELIEVES
WILL IMPROVE THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: ALSO LIFE AND
DEATH.
90% OF THE HEROIN COMING
ACROSS THAT BORDER INTO THIS
COUNTRY.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
SO, WHY WOULD NANCY PELOSI
UNDERSTAND THE PRESSURE THAT
OBAMA WAS UNDER AND
ENCOURAGE HIM TO PURSUE
OBAMACARE BUT EXPECT DONALD
TRUMP TO COMPLETELY DROP
KICK A PLAN, A PROMISE HE
MADE REPEATEDLY TO HIS BASE.
IT DOESN'T EVEN MAKE ANY
POLITICAL SENSE.
SHE UNDERSTANDS THAT.
>> Sean: LEAH, TALKING ABOUT
LITERALLY THEY ALL TOOK
THEIR VACATIONS FOR
CHRISTMAS.
THEY DIDN'T STAY AND
NEGOTIATE FOR THE FURLOUGHED
EMPLOYEES.
10 DAYS IN AND THEN HAVE YOU
GOT OTHER DEMOCRATS TAKING A
LOBBYIST-PAID JUNKET TO
LUXURIOUS RESORT IN PUERTO
RICO.
LOOKS LIKE THEY WERE HAVING
FUN.
THEN HAVE YOU NANCY GOING
AWAY AND IN THAT SEVEN DAY
PERIOD THAT MEANS THOSE
800,000 FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES
WOULD NOT GET ANOTHER CHECK.
SHE SEEMINGLY DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT THEM ALTHOUGH SHE
CLAIMS TO CARE.
BUT WE HAVE GOT LIFE AND
DEATH.
WE HAVE NEW RADICALS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OUTSPOKEN
ANTI-SEMITES, ASSOCIATIONS
WITH THE WOMEN'S MARCH.
AND THOSE PEOPLE THAT
SUPPORT FARRAKHAN.
I DON'T HEAR ANY CRITICISM
AMONGST THE DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP ABOUT ANY OF
THIS.
>> AND YOU WON'T AND IT GETS
EACH WORSE, SEAN.
AL SHARPTON, WHO THEY
ASSOCIATE OF FARRAKHAN IS
BEING VISITED BY MANY OF
THESE PERSPECTIVE
PRESIDENTIAL CAP DEMOCRATS.
BLOOMBERG, CORY BOOKER.
ELIZABETH WARREN, GILLIBRAND
HAVE ALL MET WITH THEM OR
PLANNING ON MEETING WITH
HIM.
AL SHARPTON HAS NOT
RENOUNCED HIS FRIENDSHIP
WITH FARRAKHAN.
HAS NOT RENOUNCED THE
ANTI-SEMITIC COMMENTS YOU
JUST PLAYED.
BY THE WAY YOU MENTIONED
STENY HOYER THE HOUSE
MAJORITY LEADER, HE ALSO
SAID THAT WALLS SOMETIMES
EVEN WORK.
SO NOT ONLY HAS HE BROKEN
AWAY FROM NANCY PELOSI A
LITTLE BIT, HERE HE IS
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT WALLS,
QUOTE:  SOMETIMES WORK.
I THOUGHT THEY DIDN'T WORK.
I THOUGHT THEY WERE
INEFFICIENT AND WASTE OF
MONEY?
>> Sean: I THOUGHT IT WAS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
WHY WOULDN'T NANCY MEET WITH
ANGEL MOMS AND DADS?
SHE WAS IN HIS OFFICE.
THEY WERE OUTSIDE HER DOOR.
>> YOU KNOW WHY SHE WOULDN'T
MEET.
WHAT'S SHE GOING TO SAY?
>> Sean: HOW ABOUT I'M SORRY
FOR YOUR LOSS?
I'M SO SORRY?
>> SHE SAID ABOUT A POLICE
OFFICER WHO WAS KILLED,
WELL, WE DON'T LIVE IN A
PERFECT WORLD.
REALLY?
WHENEVER THERE IS A MASS
SHOOTING, THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT SAY WE DON'T LIVE IN A
PERFECT WORLD.
WANT TO DRAFT MORE LAWS TO
RESTRICT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
RESPONSE WE DON'T LIVE IN A
PERFECT WORLD.
SATISFIED WHEN THERE IS A
MASS SHOOTING.
WHEN A PEPPER IS KILLED BY
ILLEGAL ALIEN, HEY, STUFF
HAPPENS.
WE DON'T LIVE IN A PERFECT
WORLD.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.